but now the Democracy offenders that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right the blowhards in the Democrat
Party want America to believe that
they're the true saviors of democracy
they'll take almost any opportunity to
evangelize on that topic
people doubt that elections are on the
level that is the beginning of the end
of this wonderful democracy democracy
starts flying out the window in some
other form of autocracy comes in when
conspiracy theories like the big lie are
allowed to grow well we all saw what
could happen on January 6th
lame lame lame Chucky but how are
Democrats respecting democracies of
flies out the window when their
president tries to usurp congress's
spending power with billions and
billions of student loan forgiveness
of course the Supreme Court's going to
strike that down just like they struck
down as unconstitutional vaccine mandate
for large private companies nice try Joe
now if the Biden team cared about
preserving democracy the system they
wouldn't be pulling this nonsense
and they're also spitting on our
democratic system when they repeatedly
failed to hold the FBI accountable
when the public sees how the doj targets
conservatives and then lets liberals
skate
well faith in our rule of law shattered
let's take a look at the hardened
criminals that your justice department
sent these armed agents to go terrorize
on that morning here they are here they
are at Mass
here's the seven children
with Mr Houck and his wife he has
offered to turn himself in
and this is who you go to terrorize the
politicization of the department is a
problem
and you can tell your department not a
chance in hell we're going to be
reauthorizing that thing without some
major major reforms has the Department
of Justice brought even a single case
under the statute say yes no question
the job of the United States Marshals is
to defend the lives so the answer is no
Garland was thoroughly unconvincing
and so much for the concept of Fitness
for office now any democratically
elected official who cares about the
process at a minimum must be physically
and mentally capable of doing their job
they have to be capable of managing a
crisis of processing information that's
sometimes complicated and even details
that are conflicting
yet no one on earth believes that Joe
Biden is calling the shots in either
foreign or domestic policy
the man has trouble remembering the
names of his own cabinet members his own
Supreme Court Justices or world leaders
thank you that fellow Down Under
thank you very much Val I want to thank
the SEC the the former General I keep
calling him General my my uh the guy who
runs that outfit over there those are
the words of kajal katanji drowned
Jackson happy birthday to you happy
birthday dear Valley
happy birthday to you
the man doesn't even know where he is on
any given day and we're supposed to
believe that he's directing our Ukraine
policy
welcome at Kingswood Community Center
actually that's the one down I used to
work as a joke you didn't know where you
were anyway
uh Mr President thank you he's in the
values reflected in the aana NH
Pi III
okay there's actually nothing to laugh
about the old chap just isn't all there
in 2020 the Press hated Trump so much
that they were willing to play defense
for Biden who's an absentee candidate
now ultimately the country elected a
hologram
and as a result now pivotal decisions
affecting our nation's future are being
made by kind of a combo of bureaucrats
technocrats or Obama holdovers for whom
no one voted
so this is how I see the days unfolding
for Biden in the White House the chief
of staff Jeff Zions tells Biden what
type of weapons the generals want for
Ukraine and Biden nods uh M100 tanks
okay give him a bunch
but Susan Rice pushes some executive
order on new Equity standards across the
government and Biden mutter's yeah sure
why not but Jill usually orders my food
with MSG no MSG
e-s-g-m-sc he doesn't know the
difference
now contrast Biden with Trump
you know the staff brought proposals to
him he considered them he brought in
opposing points of view he was the Oval
Office pretty much all day he had the
the different voices argue in front of
him
he wanted opposing points of view then
he made decisions
he was a Hands-On leader
no one thinks Biden is Hands-On
hands he maybe
now the voters know the truth they were
Hoodwinked
the results of a new survey is terrible
news for Joe nearly 7 in 10 registered
voters now say he's too old for another
term and more Democrats agree 48 percent
than disagree 34 with that view yikes
so the people get shafted and democracy
remember they're protecting it it seems
like a joke when we have a figurehead
president
and speaking of Charades what about the
people of California who voted to
re-elect Dianne Feinstein almost five
years ago
she turns 90 in June and has been in
poor health for a long time
this description from the LA Times about
her condition was in 2018.
as Feinstein campaigned it was clear she
had lost more than a few steps speaking
to a large Gathering of democratic
activists a month before the election
the senator seemed heavily scripted and
controlled by staff and leaned on others
to answer questions during a limited
give and take
how does anything about that sound
familiar to you guys
and now Feinstein is in the hospital
missing 11 votes this week alone because
she has a case of the shingles which you
probably know causes agonizing nerve
pain
it's terrible for her and it's corrosive
to democracy
the 40 million Californians deserve an
active Senator capable of answering real
questions
it should make all of us both sad and
mad
about the poor people of Western
Pennsylvania who are exposed to the East
Palestine trained railment Fallout
nobody's doing anything to help us said
Patty Barber who lives in Darlington
Pennsylvania less than one mile from the
spill site Pennsylvania is being left
out
so who's fighting for them in the Senate
well not John fetterman he's in the
hospital for the foreseeable future for
clinical depression meaning Pennsylvania
has only one functioning senator
now what a warped view of democracy that
is
the press the state democratic party and
fetterman's wife Giselle all knew the
guy was a mess and they didn't care
they pushed him to run anyway
so now the people of his State terrified
of this toxic spill need their Senator
present and he can't be there
of course though the reason Biden
doesn't want to travel to the derailment
side is because
we don't want to see our president
attached to a teleprompter at a time
like this we want a conversation
from a man who understands the issues
and is clear about the solutions
well that ain't in Biden's wheelhouse
[Applause]
I've spoken with every official in Ohio
Democrat and Republican on a continuous
basis as in Pennsylvania I laid out a
little bit in there what I think the
answer is
yeah no rush
why why bother reassuring the people
there let another month pass
now the only thing that our Defenders of
democracy care about is making sure they
win in 2024 and if it means blocking and
tackling again for Biden they'll do it
when they announce it
who will end up doing more damage to the
nation's faith in democracy the man who
destroyed our energy Independence
wrecked our economy and bungled the
withdrawal from Afghanistan
or those rioters who stormed the Capitol
building
hint the answer rhymes with Haydn
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else